I got on all blue they gonna be like
CMAC they're going crazy on the
internet are you and seac back together
again depends on what week I ask you
right yeah we were together and and I
kind of like dipped out a little bit we
broke up for right now we're like a on
and off relationship mhm he's an
interesting character oh yeah but I
don't you're an interesting couple right
I don't think that he can really handle
me honestly so I kind of have to dip out
this go round like I have to really make
some things happen for myself and my
daughter and he does not like my
daughter being on the street so we're
arguing about that do you like your
daughter being on the streets heck no
heck no it was just her birthday I'll
talk about that and I'mma tell you what
she
did she is off the chain is she
following in Mom's
footsteps see what I think she's doing
she's following in my highlights she's
trying
to so are we starting
yeah I feel like my daughter
is she's trying to be like how my
interviews are or how I am now and she's
not realizing that in between that I
went through a lot of stuff and that's
what I tried to say in the interview not
because of her because that was my truth
my daughter was running away at that
time but
I didn't know she was going to be on fig
I thought she was just running away and
I was just telling my truth it just she
a bright young girl thank you is and you
know I tried to
groomer the best way that I could but
she picks up bad habits out on the
streets and I don't like that cuz every
time I see her like I just seen her like
okay her birthday was 5 days ago and she
was on live okay taking a peret and I'm
like what and people were hitting me up
like your daughter's on live crying for
you so I called her phone like where are
you at like happy birthday I already
said happy birthday to her I made a post
on Instagram because one thing about her
is she's on Instagram a lot you can hit
her phone nothing but soon as you go on
Instagram she's responding so that's why
I go on
Instagram and I hit her up on Instagram
no I made a post about her and then
that's when people were like oh she's on
live right now so then I called her
phone like are you on live and she end
up answering she's like yeah Mom where
are you at um d d so I went to go pick
her up she was at the SLO and swap me I
went to go pick her up she said her
friend left her I just was like talking
to her and whoever she was with she was
with somebody else she was like oh we
got left I'm like on your birthday you
need to watch who you're around all I
could do at this point mark she the
streets got my daughter's head I'm
talking about there's nothing that I can
even say to her like I could pep talk
her I could give her good pointers
anything she's not going to listen is
there a dude involved there's a few
dudes involved and really probably girls
that she's trying to follow after that's
what I think and she's going to be mad
like I'm not trying to be a follower yes
you are because where did you get this
stuff from like your mother was not on
fig me being a sugar baby is not being
on fig fig comes with the pimp it comes
with problems um you're a minor you're
making the spot hot first of all and
it's a lot of young girls who are like
like they're really like they don't know
whether to beat her up when they see her
or to talk to her you get say saying
like don't nobody want to put their
hands on a minor and I say beat her up
because out there in those streets
anything goes like you know like
somebody could be mad oh you're a minor
making money oh who do you think you are
oh um you're making the police come over
here all type of stuff and it's just
like I'm not even there to help her she
does not want my help and when I say
there's nothing that I could say if a
kid is not listening being rebellious
what can you do like I have lost a few
pounds stressing over my daughter like I
was a little a little bit thicker than
this and it's not like I really care
about my weight but I do because that's
Health that's my mental health and so
besides that fact when I pulled up on my
daughter I talked to her she was looking
toe up I got her hair done um I got her
outfit we talked we went to go get
something to eat some food so I talked
to her and her friend I'm like okay what
do you want to do for your birthday she
let me know what I want to do what she
want to
do right after that I'm like okay like
are you going to come home let's go to
the doctor let's go get checked she went
with me we went to the doctor the next
day I get a phone call now mind you I am
a mother so you know I have to handle
business so if I tell my child stay in
the house I don't expect for you to run
away I can't take you everywhere I go
with me I did that once before it was
annoying she just wanted to stay in the
car I don't have time for that so okay
she's at home and I get a phone call cuz
I have a sitter there watching her and
her sisters and of course she can watch
your sisters too but you're supposed to
be in the house I get a phone call she
busted up all the
TVs she busted up the TVs um she left
and then I text her like did you leave
did you mess up the TVs oh yeah Mom I
was mad I'm sorry I'll get some more
money to get them fixed wait a minute
wait a minute just because you could go
out on fig or call a trick or whatever
you think that you could just bust
somebody's [__] up that's what I don't
like and what people don't understand
when I came like my first interview um
right after I did my first interview
with you Mark I went on a reality TV
show I already had children's services
on my ass about my daughter from running
away not fig yet so I went on the
reality show trying to act all you know
keeping the classy because I had uh
social workers looking at my every move
well my daughter had lied okay to the
social worker and she admitted but she
lied just to be at somebody else's house
um that I used to hit her so she was
running away and they told my daughter
like in order to stay here you have to
make a police report on your mom and you
have to say that you're getting beat
because we can't Harbor a minor so I
guess this lady had like a foster care
license she thought that was about to be
her foster Mama they was just planning
like they about to live with each other
probably split the check on some ghetto
[__] right okay um I find out I end up
blowing the whole spot she end up being
mad at me she kept running away over to
this house so I just felt like if I went
on a reality TV show just you know
acting hostile aggressive it was going
to match up with what my daughter was
lying and saying so when my daughter
confessed you know I tried my best we
even went out to Vegas we went out to
Texas we went out to where my mom lives
it did not work she even went to jail
out there she went to jail for 2 weeks
cuz Texas they don't play for pros no
not even prostitution cuz it wasn't
prostitution yet until we came back um
so she went out there and she ended up
hitting my mom and my mom was like I'm
calling the police cuz my mom don't play
that so my my mom called the police
Texas has different laws and they took
her to jail for
assault when they took her to jail for
assault she went to jail for two weeks
my mom was like don't talk to her don't
put you know no money on the phone like
let her really like suffer I couldn't
let my baby suffer because I'm like this
is her first time like I don't want her
talking to nobody and I feel like the
only wrong thing that I have done as a
mother is kind of like be too lant with
her you know like or nice because she's
me I see innocent pretty cute face I'm
like a baby but then when she be doing
all what she doing I don't be right
there like when she busted the TVs I'm
not right there when she's on fig I'm
not right there that's why she has to
run away to do it because if she could
do it in my house she would do it like
has has has all
the attention the the social media Fame
been a problem I mean that's what seems
like to be a problem with you guys man a
total problem like um I think she likes
it I really think that she you like it
too though oh no no I mean I like it as
far as you know me I'm like a
motivational speaker too so I like to
get my story out there be transparent to
kind of like vent myself and to help
others like for real real [__] like I
could be down and out and I'll still
help somebody you know because it's just
in me I'm not like oh I got to wait till
I get my [__] together then I'm going to
help you no and then it's therapeutic
for me talking about my problems to
other women or young girls or whatever
but my daughter I never knew that that
would be the young girl that I would
have to
um motivate um set a good example for
but but you could set a good example but
she not looking at me she probably
looking at sexy red y'all saying me I
see the comments oh you know um apple
don't fall too far from the tree she has
a father too that is off the goddamn
chain first of all he was doing the same
[__] at 12 years old robing stealing and
doing all that stuff you get what I'm
saying from his family and um burning
his Bridges with with his family and
something that he did at 12 years old is
still kicking his ass right now we're
not going to say but you know the
streets is a [__] so it's like I
tell my daughter like you know what
you're doing right now you're molding
your life [__] what I did [__] with
somebody else did this is your life you
know she don't care about that
motivational [__] she don't care about
that black power uh sister Soldier [__]
she don't care so I'm like okay and I am
a sweet woman I am a sweet girl but I do
have a feisty side Mark and I don't
think that my daughter really can handle
remember I was talking about my mom how
strict she was like she wants me to be
more of her friend you know but I'm not
your friend I'm your mom so when I
discipline you you can't just jet out
and then she calls me oh Mom like she
calls me like last night oh yeah I just
got into tour with this girl I told her
I was on such and such street I don't
care if she pulls up I'm like why are
you starting [__] she like um it's okay
Mom I don't care cuzz everybody want to
fight me anyway so she just causes all
these problems is she not in school
right now she don't want to go to school
she do not want to go to school this
girl cannot even when I had her for a
birthday bro you have to be at home for
at least two days for me to even check
you in then the way she just abruptly
just comes you know it'll be the weekend
and then she'll get a few days 13 14
year old should be in school yeah that
should be in school and she does not
want to go it's like I'll drag her to
school but all she going to do is cause
problems in Texas she was getting in
trouble at school they were putting her
in like um in school suspension ISS
right where you're in trouble at school
then they kicked her out of the school
how about this so she was already on the
little Texas probation and they um told
me like oh yeah she's going to have to
go to an alternative school I'm like I'm
not about to be in all list in Texas
when I could be doing this you going to
[__] around and get hung in the South
messing with these people so I'm just
like you know what so I asked her when
we came back to LA I said okay you're
turning and this was last year I said
you're turning 13 so what what are you
trying to do with your life I just want
to go stay with my
grandma so I drove from out there we
went to Grandma's house grandma was like
my gy was like I'm too old I cannot well
I can't take no kids especially no
disrespectful kids so I said please just
help me you know she say she's going to
do good I dropped her off
24 hours later I'm getting a phone call
talking about this is my grandma crying
in tears oh she just cash app $300 from
my cash app to somebody else cuz my
grandma live in the valley she's like um
yeah um Marina Valley she's like oh
um that was my last of my money she was
like um I think she got a uber because
whatever so we found out she got a uber
um oh because um my credit card just
called me and told me she tried to
charge that first and it didn't work so
she went to my cash app so now you
robbing your grandma now it reminds me
of her dad so I'm like you know what bro
but at the end of the day I already know
life is just full of adversity you know
what I'm saying and no matter what you
have to keep on going you have four you
have four other kids too yes and I have
four other kids and you have to keep on
going so imagine if because of her
having five of
these oh and I have four girls too yeah
so going to be like my big sister oh my
my my daughter's my daughter Mis she's
four she's like when I got back home
she's like um Mom Nene busted the t Nova
but Nene busted the TV
up and it's just like they're seeing
this type of stuff you get what I'm
saying if I didn't care about her she
wouldn't be nowhere near me if I cared
about what the internet said or she's
something else like and then the minute
she left and did that before I could get
get to her she was already online like
my
mother she called me weird you was just
talking to me I just picked you up for
your I just spent like $400 $500 on you
on your birthday even though money is
not nothing cuz we know she can go get
it but it's just the point like with
with your mother who didn't care about
you spend her earned I didn't I didn't
put it online that I did it I didn't
Vlog and say oh yeah we're going
shopping I didn't let Instagram though I
was lowkey Mark before she really was
out here I had to put out a missing
report for her everything you know what
I'm saying so I had to put myself in her
situation I was not trying to hide it or
nothing I never was embarrassed or
nothing I think her dad was embarrassed
but her dad went to go pick her up and
he pulled up
to
bans
rims
flashy like come on now like her daddy
is somebody out here right whatever and
I couldn't believe it cuz I'm like I
couldn't get him to pull up but you can
so you know your daddy love you no he
don't oh he came too late in my life D
but he came to get you cuz I've been
trying to get in touch with this [__]
and look it took for you so she's not
realizing what you know your blessings
come in a disguise it don't even come
how you wanted to come so maybe okay you
did all this your daddy came back in the
picture this was your test to see and he
even told her Mark like if you need
anything let me know but she so want to
make her own money like why do you want
to make your own money so bad and then I
told her do YouTube do this do that oh
no it's fake you fake she out here lying
and she out here doing everything but I
told my whole life and I got chewed out
so I basically I wanted to say another
thing like they count you the [__] out
when you tell the truth they count you
out but when you lying oh yeah
everything is all good oh yeah come in
they love lies I'm sitting here telling
y'all the truth you know what I'm saying
and I'm no better than nobody I told
y'all I'm just regular but not regular
and I'm not regular because I'm making
sure I'm not going to be regular I don't
want to be regular I'm trying to teach
Y'all [__] and it's just like H and
now I'm becoming a legend out here in
these streets and everybody wants to
talk [__] and say oh the mom must not
give a [__] man y'all know our Mas gave
a [__] and we still did whatever we
wanted to do let's be for real we live
in LA it's so many [__] out here this is
not a little small town this is the big
city baby so where out here but what's
your relationship like now with your mom
and dad so that's why in my interview I
was like my relationship is not really
that good with my mom now because every
time it gets
better um and something goes bad in my
life like for instance my daughter not
trying to blame my daughter but my mom
looks down on that like I thought she
was just doing good and now she's back
mad so my mom is like if you ain't doing
all the way good she don't want to [__]
with you that's why and I feel like I
don't [__] up so much that's why I'm
telling my daughter if you [__] up so
much people just going to look at you
like I mean my daughter is going fast
fast fast oh so my mom she hit my mom
she's then stole from my grandma so you
can imagine the relationship between me
and my family now um my daughter does a
lot bro like even my baby father that I
don't talk to she was talking to him and
I posted it on my Instagram like this is
you know why is he talking to her this
is not right you know basically on some
pedophile type [__] cuz what the cuz he
had sent her some money but I don't care
because you don't talk to me so I just
was like okay whatever so I posted it
and they got my page deleted and I was
just like H that's what I'm saying you
tell the truth they want to knock you
down so even the police they don't
really help too much so I I'm going to
have to end up figuring this out but I'm
coming up with a plan for my daughter
because I know that it's real serious
the internet is involved family ain't
[__] with us it's like leaving only
me you know a lot of chaos a lot of
chaos and um you think I'm about to
sweat I don't have no time
to so busy literally taking care of kids
even and a lot of people were saying oh
well where do your kids be at obviously
somewhere away from all of this bull
crap because while I'm out in the street
or doing not out in the street doing
nothing bad but like I want my kids safe
my daughter got the whole we go out you
know we do things we still go to the
park we still go to the mall you have
all the other four kids under your yes
so what ended up happening was and the
interview when I um first sat with you
you asked me did I have my kids I had
all of them we were all like happily
ever after living in our
apartment well when I went to Texas and
my daughter end up going to jail my son
was like mom can I stay and I felt so
bad because I'm like you don't want to
come back with me and he was like I just
want to play basketball I just want to
but I knew my son he wanted the
stability he was like [__] I don't know
where we about to go now we didn't just
drove all the way out here where you
about to go next New York so he just
wanted to stay with his friends play
basketball and I'm like you know what
you you haven't even been being bad so
you can stay here with my mom I know
she's strict I know you ain't going to
get in trouble out here but I felt like
kind of less of a parent again cuz I'm
like here we go again getting split
split up and you know I want all my kids
together but I had to chunk that up so I
said okay I have four of the girls let
me just go and the fact that my daughter
is still doing what she's doing I'm like
so what do we do all this for I could
have still had my son with me so you
know I talk to my son every other day
you know how it is sometime I don't talk
to him for like a week and I'm like why
you not calling me you know cuz I'll be
just so busy and he's in Texas and he's
in Texas you know so and you have four
girls four girls um they're in school
now see at first they weren't in school
I was just like at home they were always
with me
um I got into a relationship which we
broke up already once again because of
my daughter again like y'all just don't
even know what I de with um I was dating
CAC everybody knows and when I was
dating him a lot of people was hitting
him up like you know she was on soft
white underbelly and you know she's a
sugar baby you know her daughter is a
prostitute he was like whoa what so I
had to break it down like oh what
happened was but I had to keep it real
with him like you know you've been
around gangs and all that it's kind of
like the same thing you know um it's
very addictive and it's toxic and it's
hard to get out of and he kind of
understood for a little bit but it's
like when I'm not in his face he flips
out so for the record we really broke up
because I have to be a mom and I can't
really be with him all day long how he
wants me to so I'm like damn why you
making it seem like I got so much
baggage like make it happen you know be
with me for a few days handle business
if you can't do that and you can't keep
on bringing them my daughter because if
if you're not helping like literally
don't say nothing about it you know what
what did they say if you don't have
nothing nice to say don't say it at all
so I just feel like I wasn't too hard on
him because he don't have no kids so he
don't know so people would would who
don't have kids kids is hard yeah they
be like oh I would never let my daughter
do that well reason four kids is got
five kids is got to be really hard by
yourself too and you know I never really
had no help because I told you these
guys they're so jealous of what I do
how I make money or me being around guys
other guys they you got to be strong for
that they think I'm cheating every five
minutes but whatever so me and CAC did
what we did I don't like his attitude
when it comes to like my daughter that's
what I don't like like he talks a lot of
[__] about her and he was talking she
was talking a lot of stuff about him too
I'm like stop talking about this grown
ass man I don't like him for you Mom and
then we broke up oh oh I wish you guys
were together again mom she's such a
[__] manipulative kid I'm telling you
but she's smart she gets it from me like
I I'm like if you're smart enough to be
manipulative like that you could use it
towards something else I mean you're not
going to be perfect but what you doing
is crazy as no she's a she's a very
bright young girl right but but she's
applying it in a way that's not really
going to take her she cheating she
cheating cuz let me tell you she's using
manifestation she's using um
spirituality she's using God
in a good way you know like when she
needs God as she should she prays but I
feel like because she knows that she has
that like those tools she's going to
like use them so she's like oh all I got
to do is ask God for forgiveness oh all
I got to do is you know call my mom and
she's pretty positive she'll get over it
I'm not getting over it I'm just moving
forward because like I said life is
going we're going to deal with all this
even if I was doing perfect Mark which I
was people in the comments was like cuz
they um you had uh pinned my um God
senta page right they were confused well
I had been on my spirituality I yeah I
will always forever be a sugar baby
until I get into a serious relationship
but I really took it to another level
educating myself on like life cuz I seen
my daughter growing up I seen her having
mood swings before she ran away before
she ran away I seen in her phone her
lying about her age her sending nudes
and stuff like that so I didn't know she
was going to be bold enough to go on fig
but it was when she ran away and seen
other runaways and then obviously ran
into another prostitute has nothing to
do with Mommy but coincidentally and and
it's okay because God does these things
I did the interview at the same time
that she jumped off the porch and got on
fig and she probably did take some
pointers but then she told me like Mom I
got out there and I realized like it's
not like how it seem so she knows right
but with this Fame that she has she has
to keep it going so I feel like if she
just stops maybe her little bitty mind
would think oh I threw in the towel I
couldn't do it I look like a failure I
know how you could feel but think about
this these same people who are saying
talking about you they really don't care
too much about your life they they
really just they're there for
entertainment so whatever you choose to
entertain them with be careful cuz it's
really [__] up your life at the same
time in and then they're laughing and
then you're crying at night and then
you're doing your mother like this and
you only get one mom and then you got me
as a mom [__] nah but
um I yeah I I really feel like she needs
to um I'm not disowning her but you know
what children's service is going to have
to get you because it's just like what
are you going to keep doing prostituting
until somebody kidnap your ass sodomize
your ass kill you so it's just
like she
bold I don't I I just don't get it and
it must be a guy in her ear and guess
what whoever it sucks for them because
whoever I have eight missing reports out
on her so within the year it's been
eight reports whoever goes down for this
little girl it will be human trafficking
because they just put it in that
category if they catch her across the
border let's just say Vegas they told me
that it's a federal charge so for y'all
pimps out there thinking y'all about to
get Nova and all of that a pimp I'm
telling you called me like um last month
and he was like I got your daughter and
I got her but she left again so the
internet doesn't know how many times she
leaves she just left she going out of
town huh she told me she's going to
other oh cities I don't know if it's out
of state or not I forget like I said
they will be charged with a federal
freaking and the police are so strange
because she's told me like yeah Mom I
I've gotten pulling pulled over um with
people and all I have to do is lie about
my
age they don't do no fingerprint they
don't do no running on nothing so it's
just like she's just getting away with a
lot of stuff and I just pray to God that
really like my prayer is that she just
wakes up one day and just says I'm tired
of this like I'm better than this like I
could get money like this when I'm 18
and over I'm about to get my education
I'm about to boss up like be bossy you
get what I'm saying like be bossy like
don't look at what I'm doing be better
than me but do you think her seeing mom
doing whatever she's doing she know that
Mom doing what she have to do I got I
got family that always you know kind of
hated on me a little bit um they don't
like my lifestyle so it's no support so
you don't have no support you kind of
like make relationships with people who
don't give a [__] anyway the cmax the
guys in the street the sugar daddies
because that is your support you know
and it's like like I'm human too so I'm
like you know a sugar daddy may make me
feel good too and I can make him feel
good but that's my situation what's
yours it's look what year it is we're in
technology you could do so much more you
don't have to do what somebody else is
doing everybody is different like I'm
really curious to see what my daughter
with all of this experience that she's
had and what she's been through
like what can she come up with it could
be something really good mhm you know we
could really like be together like if I
could get her right here with me to
really talk this out and really be for
real that I would know by how she's
talking maybe next time maybe next time
it's just like I don't know what's going
to have to give that's why I've been on
I've been writing some more ebooks I got
ebooks and stuff it's all on my page um
y'all need to follow me I love tore on
Instagram do do you think your social
media presence and you being on that
show has caused some of these problems
um because because kids see what mom's
doing I I I do I really do like but I
don't know why they do that like you
guys you cannot look at it's all edited
like kids are going to do what mom does
not what mom says exactly but it's like
how how can you make that decision at
that age like what about kids that
listen like you're not afraid of the
consequences like okay I'm doing what
Mom does and she may whoop my ass no
like
they not even afraid and then let's just
say I beat her to she black and blue
what is that going to do a pimp could do
that too she's going to run right into
the arms of a pimp like oh baby I got
you no so you looking at what I'm doing
but okay look at my age look at your
age and people want to know my
age I want to ask you know I'm just
keeping everything G I'm keeping the
ganga because I don't want people
thinking like that I'm lying and I'm
trying to be this I am being exactly who
I am okay I'm a Scorpio woman woman of
God um and when I say woman of God I
just know who my source is that's it you
know I know what's here for me I know
who will always have things for me
because when you be in this world
feeling alone you sometime you be like
is there a god so when I say a woman of
God I'm basically acknowledging God's
presence and you know my belief in him
so and this is a crazy world out here
you were a handful for your mom right
was I but I boss my mom up she always
tell me oh if it wasn't for you I
wouldn't have been this my mom is a real
estate agent look you think she giving
me a house no real estate agent um my
mom lives in Texas you think she out
here trying to help me no because I'm
grown now or because I she live her life
so I tell my daughter like I have not
left you you get what I'm saying while
you're getting all the help while you're
young get all the help that you can cuz
soon as you 18 people don't got time for
you they got to deal with their own life
and I stress my mom out so much she's
like girl with the knowledge that you
know you don't need my help so that's
how I look at my daughter you know so
much and you're making these decisions
like you ain't trying to go to school I
told her at 13 I was in leadership and I
wasn't trying to be uh better than her
or whatever like oh I was in leadership
but I'm just saying those are things
that kids do I wanted to walk around the
school I wanted to be all in the
yearbook and talking to people so you
got to be in leadership and that's
probably why I'm a leader so I'm like
why are you not doing those things she
stopped dancing she knows how to dance
really
good she just trying to be grown and I
hate it at such a young age such a young
age and I said well you're cute now but
you know after being crying every day
stressing out you know your face start
to change um you start to break out
you're not taking care of yourself
properly you can't be soft like your
mama because your mama not telling you
to take a shower and you know uh oil
down so things like that she's still
very much a little kid on
online she be popping it like she just
so grown and you know she even be
looking a little a little bit older but
I know my baby you know what's your
dream situation to be in in like 2 3
years oh
really my dream is for me to be in a big
house o I wanted to be like five bedroom
for real I wanted to be a big house I'll
take four three or four okay I want my
daughter to be there with me I want all
my kids to be in my house for real I
want my income coming like I told you my
ebooks I want young girls to be bossing
up because I can't go down in history
just like the 304 mama and the 304
daughter and that's it like we're from
La like like this is lowkey a disgrace
for South Central because it's like they
got fig looking all good but our real
life is really in shambles and I was
just up there and now I'm kind of like
low you know cuz I can't really move
forward without thinking about like what
about my daughter or what about this but
it also motivates me so I know in about
a few years with this going on I'm just
pushing myself to have that big old
house to have my ebooks all the way out
I have about four of them right now so
click the link in my bio to um go
download all of my ebooks and I will be
like coming out with more like month for
month see last time I told you I wanted
businesses a eBook that's a business too
and also maybe something with my
daughter you know what I'm saying I just
want to I want to be in cahoots with my
daughter right now because if I like
steer away from her I feel feel like she
just going to be
lost just lost so I'm I'm really
thinking Mark
like I don't I just know I want to be
doing well for myself because I just was
almost on my way and like these
relationships like when I get in these
relationships I told you like last time
it always comes down to the same thing
you ain't nothing but a hoe or now it's
your daughter is a hoe so at this point
I'm just going to focus
on me my kids my daughter something to
change her and to change me and to make
some type of money as a business so that
that could be our life and we could just
know we went through a tough time and we
helped oursel and we helped other people
too however I'm going to do it that's
how I want to do it but that's what I
see myself
doing what do you call it philanthropy
mhm work but like making it into like a
business cuz I'm serious helping others
all right hm helping others yeah helping
others like this [__] is ridiculous and
then it's like oh I can't go nowhere
without getting recorded oh ain't you
the girl that I'll be running Mark they
be seeing me you have to take
responsibility for that you created that
cuz you're like a big social media
person now yeah and then they got my
page knocked down like I was growing my
followers I had 25k they got my page
knocked down reporting my daughter
that's why I have other Pages you know
for her cuz people be hating you know
they think that can you believe that
they think that I was using my daughter
for clout and they said that I put her
out on fig like I'm the one doing that
could you like the [__] that they but
she be lying though she'll she'll tell
people oh I got kicked out or because I
think she's like using somebody else's
story she do be out here though she do
but like how she got out there is not so
she got to like kind of make it add up
with what the internet saying so that
she could kind of be accepted or
something but if she told the truth like
no I really like
this that's what she we got to get you
guys in here together right like I need
to get her here
because different the truth is going to
come out cuz she knows she can't really
lie too much and if she do she G to
start
laughing like
Mom like girl you show ain't mom on that
internet you be popping about me she
just called me a weirdo the other day
I'm like
weird but if I call you a weirdo I'm a
bad mom
right but it's messed up though I I love
my daughter though um I've been fighting
for her since I get the feeling she
loves you too but it's just raising
teenagers is is tough I've been fighting
for that little girl literally I was
pregnant with her fighting okay guys I
mean not guys girls you know her dad was
somebody that girls liked and they used
used to be mad and I had to fade a few
people with her like I could have lost
her that's why I be looking like if you
was going to do all this could shove you
back up my [__] but I kept
you
and can't wait for her to just grow up
for real you know so she could be I'm
like when are you going to be a real
person cuz at this point I feel like
you're just a social media person you
remind me of one of
these people on social media that like
me one day and hate me next it's like
you know you really love me and you know
you looking at everything I'm doing cuz
I be looking at her like hey you took
that from me like you've been looking at
my interview or
something my mannerisms or I mean you
better take something good for me but
she she reminds me of you really
mhm and imagine how she acts when I'm
not around like
girl but um I'm I'm I'm trying to keep
it together
but you know I'm trying to find love
though for real cuz I'm tired of dealing
with this on my own so you know I broke
up with CMAC but I'm kind of like seeing
somebody just it's somebody to keep my
head level you know I would never like
neglect my kids for a guy oh no no no
they know I love my kids I got to always
make that like very specific when I talk
to anybody cuz I don't want them to get
the wrong idea you know I'm all happy
and googly and lovey but I'm like hold
on you know I do got kids and you got to
respect me and my kids right so that's
why CAC me and him could never work
because he don't he got a baby on the
way
too so we was talking at you know the
beginning of the year or not beginning
but in the middle of the year the summer
we were talking and we broke up he went
and got a girl pregnant so then four
months later we got with each other and
again and he was like yeah I have a baby
on the way but you know I want you to
support me and I think he got to turn
himself in next week so he's like are
you going to be down for me but I can't
be down for somebody who's talking mess
about my daughter
and just because of what the comments
say you chewing me like you know out
like we could be laying in the bed and
all cool and if a Blog is out like they
chopped me up with your interview and
made me seem like I was just a setup
artist like I was going to set him up
and Rob him any second I'm like no
that's not what I said in the interview
social media is just crazy yeah the
comments and all that and so opinions I
never was at ease you know I'm I'm like
I need somebody that can really take a
bad [__] and you know I'm GNA find it
Mark cuz you know I get what I want I
don't play I do not play you know is the
only thing that I can't get what I want
right now is my daughter because she has
her own mind and we're kind of like
going off of it sounds crazy but we're
literally going off of what this little
young lady is doing
because she has her Free Will so so it's
like unless we're directing her
footsteps and but who's going to do all
that I want her to make her bed cuz she
going to have to lay in
it I can't hold your hand I can't you
know my mom didn't hold my hand and if
she would have stressed out the whole
time I was running away my mom she
wouldn't had no real estate license and
everything went bad for her when I left
her husband left she got a divorce she
found out he was cheating he had a baby
on all of this crazy stuff right and
that was just wasn't you know my mom
Stilo like she's like a baddy too so
it's kind of like embarrassing like my
my husband is doing this to me and my
daughter kind of reminds me of
me so I'm like okay I learned from my
mom already so I tell my baby it's not
like I don't care but mama got to keep
it pushing and I'm going to be right
here but I'm not going to take you as
serious so depending on what decisions
you making you better watch
it and you know she don't like that
that's why she haven't came back yet
that's exactly why she wants me to say
okay you can go prostituting and come
back on home
baby why you being weird to me talking
about I'm a weirdo but
whatever I'm not a kid y'all I just look
young but I am still young got me [__]
up this is 35 years of
hard
work and Chaos no really chaos and
living in La like when I look on
Instagram all the girls who don't live
in LA oh they have like a soft life
everything is all the minute you see you
could tell when a girl from La stress
they're fast fast bags under your eyes
[__] smoked out we don't even
we don't even eat until we smoke a blunt
around here and that's what I don't like
that's what I don't like so I do have
two sides to me so people say it's two
sides I have a soft side and I have a
real life side so you guys done got the
other side out of me because of my
daughter and the other side I'mma always
keep it cute cuz that's the only way
it's the only way to live you cannot
look like what you've been through and
you cannot let people see you sweat but
I am vulnerable and transparent too and
I don't got no shame in my game and when
I do need to talk to somebody I do so I
don't give a [__] you know people be
like I don't tell nobody nothing tell
somebody something talk to somebody okay
cuz you need it it's good for your
health all right T thank you so much
for clearing the air on some of this uh
yes drama yes we're going to pin my
right YouTube but yeah you guys follow
me or whatever and I love y'all I love
the good comments I see what y'all
saying and we going to get through this
we going to figure something out any
suggestions y'all let me know cuz you
never know these comments you know may
be somebody out there that
can help you out yeah all right thank
you Mark I wish you lots of luck thank
you with your
teenager